something about the world series has
always bothered me because it's the
world series but the only two T of the
only teams in it are from the US and
Canada they're the only ones that get to
compete that's a really good point Andy
and I'm glad you brought it up because
it was on cards what most people I can
read good yeah
[Applause]
and now I'm gonna say something off the
cuff all right what most people don't
know is that the World Series is a truly
global event you see it couldn't happen
without participation from countries all
over the world check it out France
provides the champagne to celebrate the
wins right sure China manufactures all
the uniforms okay Venezuela and Cuba
provide all the players all right yeah
yeah Russia Russia provides the
performance-enhancing drugs you got to
have those or yeah kenya produces the
coffee that keeps fans awake for nine
innings that takes yeah that's a lot
alum BIA provides the base lines I don't
he ever thought about that
who's worried yeah
Estonia Estonia ships over the players
mistresses all right Mongolian Weaver's
handloom all the players beards that
takes a lot of work every night yeah
Ireland Ireland plays a big role Ireland
ships over giant Irish babies to work as
umpires Peruvian alpacas provide you
eager Hills hair and finally a landfill
in Kazakhstan produces the hotdog so you
have working together nice to make a
world series
you